indeed a great victory for him darius
this tournament has not been one where
you're fighting for first i know you'd
rather be in that position but getting a
good win closer and seemingly more and
more solid as this tournament has gone
on uh you've been holding your own
i mean yeah
the tournament is
over in the sense of me playing for the
top places but still there's you know i
thought after this today there are still
two games to go
uh let's just play chess let's do my
best and
see how it goes of course it's better to
finish the tournament
with i mean not with a loss of course
so uh yesterday it was a tough game for
me of course but
you know i've tried to forget about and
just try to do my best in the last two
rounds so far according to the plan
hopefully tomorrow will be the same
you i know you have other tournaments
coming up yes your next tournament is uh
fidel grand swiss is the grand swiss is
this allowing you to see where the holes
are or maybe patch up some difficulties
definitely definitely it's a great uh
you know preparation i mean like
we die uh and we still i mean like i was
forgotten the same going it's like we
die and we we are born uh stupid and we
die stupid like or something like that
right that's i think it's polish
so basically what i'm trying to say is
like every day is a learning experience
so um
yeah like i'm very happy to
you know
play here and because
each game
you know is against very strong player
so i can learn something from it better
to play well in the next tournament yes
definitely as you're trying to qualify
for the world championship
you see this tournament you see how
bunched up it is at the top
do you feel like just a little bit
different than you could have maybe been
in the mix i mean definitely like i
missed this tournament i missed couple
of chances uh like against alexanderman
samsung both games i in both games i was
winning
against some wasn't easy but against
alex i saw the win and i just got
confused myself and
couldn't
couldn't you know convert it
and yeah like if i won these two games i
have one extra points to the situation
right now it's totally different even
after i lost to fabi so
you know he could have gone either way
but
sometimes it's just like that so i'm
i'm happy definitely that i could
you know
play those games because i know like
that you know sometimes my conversion
uh of advantages requires more precision
so i will have to pay into this pay more
more uh attention to this detail in my
my future games you anticipated my
question in fact uh what have you
learned tell us one thing you've learned
from this event and you talked about the
importance of the conversion yeah of
advantages how do you train for that as
a player on your level
it's very hard to train for it because
usually what we do is just try to get
some advantage of the opening and
this is pretty much where it ends
of course there's some calculation
training and so on but this aspect is
pretty pretty tricky because i mean um
it's not something you look at at the
first time at the first instance but i
think that what would help me with some
training games with some you know better
positions trying to win them some maybe
against other players
i'm not sure if there will be enough
time before my next tournament but
you know
for the future future like definitely i
will look into that i'm going to give
you some advice uh hurry up order yasser
sirwan's book on amazon and go over his
best game no
if you want to get conversion you're not
going to give him advice
ruin your career you're promising you
have a very very promising uh future you
know the guy beat karpov kasparov
he has been tall
i would look into this yeah some good
players he's got one or two all right
well it's good to know that you are
keeping good spirits and focused on your
last game good luck thanks
good luck also in the phoenix
championship thanks yes first of all
very good luck at the riga uh feed a
championship in the
in your campaign to qualify for the
candidates
this particular event we've seen we've
seen u.s championships in the past sam
shanklin winning plus six fabiano with
plus five clear second
we've seen big scores we're seeing a
monster score in the women's section
with carissa
this year's u.s championship
plus two
is leading the whole field is this a
surprise to you it is a surprise yeah
definitely i wasn't expecting that i was
thinking that you know we like plus
three plus four maybe
not make the past five but plus four i
was sort of expecting
but uh i don't know it is the way it is
sometimes
yeah
um
maybe a tiredness by the top players
they're playing
quite a lot of events
these days
i don't know to be honest to me it seems
like
the level is just very very even
sometimes you know worse positions that
are there
like i had very tough push against
jeffrey as well and i managed to hold it
right right so um
you know like also against me players
manage to hold so basically the level is
very you know even and people try to
players try to fight ld and until
basically there is nothing to hope for
right so that's what makes the game
tough sometimes one inaccuracy is enough
for someone to save the game
thank you for your insights and good
luck tomorrow thanks and hopefully